La Naturaleza es mi musa y mi pasión.
Como fotógrafo del National Geographic, la retraté mucho.
Pero hace cinco años, comencé un viaje personal.
Quería visualizar la historia de la vida.
Es la aventura más dura
que he intentado nunca, y en muchas ocasiones he estado a punto de abandonar
También hubo revelaciones.
Y uno de ellas es la que me gustaría compartir hoy con ustedes.
Fui a una remota laguna en Australia, esperando ver la Tierra
como era hace tres mil millones de años,
antes de que el cielo se volviera azul.
Hay estromatolitos allí --
los primeros seres vivos en captar la fotosíntesis --
y ese es el único lugar donde eso ocurre actualmente
Ir allí es como entrar en una cápsula del tiempo,
y salí con un sentido diferente de mí mismo en el tiempo.
El oxígeno exhalado por los estromatolitos
es el que todos respiramos hoy.
Los estromatolitos son los héroes de mi historia.
Espero que esta historia que tenga cierta repercusión en nuestro tiempo.
Una historia sobre ti y sobre mí, naturaleza y la ciencia.
Dicho esto, me gustaría invitarles a
un corto viaje de la vida a través del tiempo.
El viaje comienza en el espacio, la materia se condensa en esferas en el tiempo.
Solidificándose en la superficie, moldeándose por el fuego.
El fuego abrió el camino, la Tierra emergió, pero como un planeta alienígena
La luna estaba más cerca, las cosas eran diferentes.
El calor interior generó géiseres en erupción,
dando pie a los océanos. El agua se congeló en torno a los polos, y dio forma a los límites de la Tierra.
El agua es clave para la vida, pero, congelada, es una fuerza latente.
Y cuando desaparece, la Tierra se convierte en Marte.
Pero este planeta es diferente - se agita en su interior
Y donde esa energía toca el agua, surge algo nuevo: la vida.
Surge alrededor de fisuras en la Tierra.
Barro y minerales se hacen sustrato, aparecen las bacterias.
Aprenden a multiplicarse, extendiéndose por todas partes.
Estructuras vitales crecen bajo un cielo extraño.
Los estromatolitos fueron los primeros exhalando oxígeno.
Y cambiaron la atmósfera.
Su aliento fosilizado es ahora como el hierro
Los meteoritos nos entregaron la química, y quizás las membranas.
La vida necesita una membrana que la contenga
para que pueda replicarse y mutar.
Estos son diatomeas, fitoplancton unicelular
con esqueletos de silicio.
Las placas de circuitos del futuro.
Los mares nutrieron la vida, y allí se transformó
en formas más complejas.
La vida creció con el oxígeno y la luz.
La vida se endureció y se puso a la defensiva.
Aprendió a moverse y a ver. Los primeros ojos crecieron en los trilobites.
La visión se perfeccionó en los cangrejos de herradura,
uno de los primeros en salir del mar.
Todavía siguen haciendo lo mismo, sus enemigos ya se fueron.
Los escorpiones siguieron a sus presas fuera del mar. Las babosas se hicieron caracoles
Los peces probaron la vida anfibia. Las ranas se adaptaron a los desiertos.
Líquenes surgieron como cooperativas. Hongos casados con algas.
Aferrándose a las rocas, y comiéndoselas también. Transformaron la tierra yerma.
Las plantas terrestres, sin hojas al principio.
Aprendieron a mantenerse verticales, crecieron en tamaño y forma.
Los tipos fundamentales de helechos las siguieron,
lanzando esporas que anunciaban las semillas.
Floreció vida en los pantanos.
En tierra, la vida dio un giro. Primero las mandíbulas. Los dientes llegaron más tarde.
La tortuga laúd y los tuátaras son ecos de aquella época.
La vida tardó bastante tiempo en romper con el agua,
y aún le atrae todavía.
La vida se volvió dura, debieron aventurarse tierra adentro.
Y aquellos dragones están aún entre nosotros.
Jurassic Park aún reluce en cierta parte de Madagascar,
y en el centro del Brasil.
Las plantas llamadas cícadas continúan tan duras como rocas.
Los bosques se alzaron y se llenaron de alas.
Las primeras especies que dejaron huellas, parece que hubiesen muerto ayer.
Y otras vuelan hoy como ecos del pasado.
En las aves, la vida adquirió nueva movilidad.
Los flamencos cubrieron los continentes. Las migraciones se pusieron en marcha.
Las aves fueron testigos de la aparición de las plantas con flores.
Los lirios de agua estuvieron entre las primeras.
Las plantas empezaron a diversificarse y crecer, convirtiéndose en árboles.
En Australia, un lirio se convertió en un árbol herbáceo,
y en Hawai, una margarita se convirtió en una "Silver Sword".
En África, Gondwana moldeaba a Proteas.
Pero cuando ese antiguo continente se separó, la vida se volvió exhuberante.
Surgieron las selvas tropicales, se crearon nuevas capas de interdependencia.
Los hongos se multiplicaron. Orquídeas surgieron, sus formas genitales atrajeron insectos.
Un truco compartido por la flor más grande en la Tierra.
Coevolución entrelazada de insectos, pájaros y plantas para siempre.
Y cuando las aves no pueden volar, se hacen vulnerables.
Como los kiwis, y estos halcones atrapados cerca de la Antártida.
La extinción puede ir despacio, pero a veces llega rápido.
Cayó un asteroide, y el mundo se vio envuelto en llamas.
Pero quedaron testigos, supervivientes en la oscuridad.
Cuando el cielo se aclaró, un nuevo mundo nació.
Un mundo para los mamíferos. Como las pequeñas musarañas,
o los tenrecs, adaptados a la oscuridad.
Nuevas especies como los murciélagos. Las civetas.
Y nuevos depredadores, las hienas, más y más veloces.
Las praderas crearon oportunidades,
La seguridad del rebaño agudizó los sentidos.
Hacerse más grandes fue otra respuesta, pero el tamaño tiene un precio.
Algunos mamíferos regresaron al agua.
Morsas adaptadas con capas de grasa. Brillantes lobos marinos.
Y los cetáceos se movieron en un mundo sin límites.
Hay muchas formas de ser un mamífero. Un canguro salta en Oz.
Un caballo corre en Asia, y un lobo evoluciona sus patas como zancos en Brasil.
Los primates emergen de la selva, como tarseros primero,
convertidos en lemures no mucho más tarde.
Su aprendizaje se vio reforzado. Grupos de monos se aventuraron a salir a la luz.
Los bosques se secaron otra vez. Caminar erguido se convirtió en estilo de vida.
Entonces, ¿quiénes somos? Hermanos de los chimpancés.
Hermanas de los femeninos bonobos. Somos todos ellos, y más.
Estamos moldeados por la misma fuerza vital.
Las venas de sangre en nuestras manos,
eco de los ríos de agua que surcan la Tierra.
nuestros cerebros - célebres cerebros -
semejan las mareas de un pantano.
La vida es fuerza en sí misma. Un nuevo elemento.
Altera la Tierra. Cubre la Tierra como una piel.
Cuando no, como Groenlandia en invierno,
Marte no parece estar muy lejos.
Pero todo desaparece al derritirse el hielo de nuevo.
Donde el agua es líquida, se hace útero.
Para células verdes con clorofila - y esta maravilla molecular
eso marca la diferencia - lo revive todo.
Todo el mundo animal vive hoy en una reserva
bacteriana de oxígeno en un ciclo constante
a través de plantas y algas, sus residuos son nuestro aliento,
y viceversa.
La Tierra está viva, y ha creado su propia membrana.
La llamamos atmósfera. Es el icono de nuestro viaje.
Y todos ustedes se pueden imaginar donde vamos ahora.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias.